>> David: WELCOME BACK TO A
SPECIAL EDITION OF "HANNITY,"
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S AMERICA FIRST
AGENDA IN FULL EFFECT.
GET THIS.
AFTER THE UNITED NATIONS, AFTER
THE UNITED STATES NEGOTIATED A
$285 MILLION CUT TO THE
UNITED NATIONS BLOATED BUDGET,
OF COURSE, THIS COMES AS
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND U.S.
AMBASSADOR NIKKI HALEY
BLASTED -- AND I MEAN BLASTED --
THE U.N. GENERAL ASSEMBLY FOR
HOLDING A VOTE TO REBUKE THE
UNITED STATES' DECISION TO MOVE
ITS EMBASSY IN JERUSALEM, AND
ISRAEL, TO JERUSALEM.
WATCH THIS.
WAS SINGLED OUT FOR ATTACK IN
THE GENERAL ASSEMBLY FOR THE
VERY ACT OF EXERCISING OUR RIGHT
AS A SOVEREIGN NATION.
WE WILL REMEMBER IT WHEN WE ARE
CALLED UPON TO ONCE AGAIN MAKE
THE WORLD'S LARGEST CONTRIBUTION
TO THE UNITED NATIONS.
AND WE WILL REMEMBER IT WHEN SO
MANY COUNTRIES COME CALLING ON
US AS THEY SO OFTEN DO TO PAY
EVEN MORE AND TO USE OUR
INFLUENCE FOR THEIR BENEFIT.
>> UNITED STATES, THE PEOPLE
THAT LIVE HERE, ARE GREAT
CITIZENS.
I LOVE THIS COUNTRY.
THEY ARE TIRED OF THIS COUNTRY
BEING TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF AND
>> David: BY THE WAY, AS AN
ADDED NOTE, GUATEMALA NOW
ANNOUNCING THAT THEY WILL MOVE
THEIR EMBASSY INTO JERUSALEM, AS
WELL.
SO I WONDER WHEN THE VOTE IS
COMING UP IN THE U.N. ON THAT.
IN THE WAKE OF THEIR
ANTI-ISRAEL, ANTI-AMERICAN
POSITIONS, AND WITH THE U.S.
CONTRIBUTING MORE, AND I SAY
MORE, TO THE U.N.'S BUDGET THAN
ANY OTHER NATION, SHOULD THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION TAKE EVEN
MORE FINANCIAL STEPS TO PUT THEM
ON NOTICE?
JOINING US NOW, FORMER
UNITED STATES AMBASSADOR TO THE
UNITED NATIONS, AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR JOHN BOLTON.
AS WELL AS COO OF THE EAST-WEST
INSTITUTE AND A RETIRED U.S.
NAVAL OFFICER, DR. BILL PROPER E
NAVAL OFFICER, DR. BILL PROPER .
"GUARANTEEING AMERICA'S SAFETY
INTO THE 21ST CENTURY."
YOU TWO HAVE BEEN AT WORK DOING
THIS JOB, FIRST, TO YOU,
AMBASSADOR BOLTON.
GREAT TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
I KNOW WHERE YOU STAND ON THIS
BUT I WANT TO HEAR IT FROM YOU.
I THINK I KNOW WHERE YOU STAND
ON THIS.
WHAT IS THIS REALLY AND WHAT
DOES IT MEAN?
>> THIS PARTICULAR CUT WAS BAKED
IN THE CAKE BEFORE THE JERUSALEM
VAULT.
CERTAINLY IT'S WORTHWHILE TO GET
THE BUDGET LOW OR EVEN BY THAT
AMOUNT.
BUT I THINK IT PROVIDES THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WITH AN
ELEMENTS OF THE U.N. SYSTEM ARE
FUNCTIONING SUCCESSFULLY AND
WHAT ARE NOT.
AND TO MOVE AWAY FROM THE SYSTEM
OF INTERNATIONAL TAXATION AND
THE FACT THAT WE ARE UNDER NOW,
AS YOU SAY, WE SAY 22% OF THE
REGULAR BUDGET, 28% OF THE EVEN
LARGER PEACEKEEPING BUDGET.
AND JUST DECIDE THAT WE ARE
GOING TO CONTRIBUTE VOLUNTARILY
TO WHAT WE THINK WORKS AND
EITHER SUBSTANTIALLY REDUCED OR
ZERO OUT OF THOSE PROGRAMS AND
OFFICES THAT WE DON'T THINK
WORK.
NOW IF THIS WOULD BE LIKE A
TSUNAMI THROUGH THE U.N. SYSTEM.
BUT IF WE COULD CARRY THROUGH
WITH IT, IT WOULD ACTUALLY MAKE
IT MORE EFFICIENT AND MORE
EFFECTIVE.
BE HERE RIGHT NOW, DR. PARKER,
HE SAYS THAT SOMETIMES IN
DIPLOMACY, YOUR CHOICES AREN'T
THAT GOOD.
I'M USING THE CLEANED UP VERSION
OF THIS.
DO YOU THINK THIS SENDS A SYMBOL
TO THE UNITED NATIONS?
SPEAK OF THE UNITED NATIONS IS A
VERY
IMPORTANT BODY.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY,
EFFICIENCY AND EFFECTIVENESS
MATTERS, AND THE REALITY IS, AS
AMBASSADOR BOLTON JUST POINTED
OUT, 22% OF THAT TOTAL FUNDING
CAME FROM UNITED STATES, 9% CAME
FROM JAPAN, AND 8% CAME FROM
CHINA AND THE REST ARE MUCH
SMALLER.
SO TO SAY THAT WE NEED TO GET
MORE EFFICIENT AND MORE
EFFECTIVE I THINK IS SPOT ON.
WE DO NEED TO TAKE A GOOD, HARD
LOOK AT THAT BUT I ALSO THINK WE
NEED TO REALIZE HOW IMPORTANT
THE UNITED NATIONS AS TO THE
OVERALL BODY OF THE GLOBE.
THEY ARE ANNOUNCING, AND OTHER
NATIONS ARE INDICATING THEY MAY
DO THIS, AND MOVING THEIR
HAVE YOU DISCERNED ANYTHING FROM
US?
>> THE GOVERNMENT OF ISRAEL HAS
BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
SOMETIME, AND I'M SURE THEY ARE
GOING TO TRY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF IT.
I THINK OTHER COUNTRIES MAY MAKE
THAT DECISION, AS WELL.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT'S BIGGEST
PROBLEM, HAVING RECOGNIZED
JERUSALEM AS THE CAPITAL OF
ISRAEL, HIS BIGGEST PROBLEM IN
MOVING THE U.S. EMBASSY IS GOING
TO BE AT THE U.S.
STATE DEPARTMENT, WHERE THEY
JUST DON'T LIKE THIS IDEA ONE
LITTLE BITE.
AND I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS A
REAL ESTATE EXECUTIVE, HE KNOWS
HOW TO GET THINGS BUILT.
MY ADVICE TO HIM WOULD BE TO
MOVE FORWARD, SELECT A SITE, DO
THE PLANNING, AND START TURNING
DIRT AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
LOOK AT MOVING IN TO US
JERUSALEM, WHICH IS WHERE ALL
THEY WOULD BECOME A WITHOUT
PREJUDICE TO THE ULTIMATE
OUTCOME OF THE PEACE
NEGOTIATION.
>> David: ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THIS, DR. PARKER, TURKEY HAS
ANNOUNCED THAT THEY ARE ALSO
GOING TO MOVE THEIR CONSULATE, I
BELIEVE IS WHAT THEY CALL IT, TO
JERUSALEM.
DOES THIS INDICATE ANYTHING
ABOUT THE GEOPOLITICAL OR THE
REGIONAL POLITICAL ISSUES?
>> IT INDICATES THAT THIS IS A
COMPLEX ENVIRONMENT AND IT'S NOT
GOING TO GET ANY EASIER ANYTIME
SOON.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS GOING
ON IN THE MIDDLE EAST, THAT
IS NOT GOING TO CHANGE.
THE COMPLEXITIES ARE THERE AND
YOU WERE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
SEE COUNTRIES DECIDE WHETHER ORN
SEE COUNTRIES DECIDE WHETHER ORT
SEE COUNTRIES DECIDE WHETHER ORE
SEE COUNTRIES DECIDE WHETHER ORY
SEE COUNTRIES DECIDE WHETHER ORW
SEE COUNTRIES DECIDE WHETHER ORN
SEE COUNTRIES DECIDE WHETHER ORT
SEE COUNTRIES DECIDE WHETHER ORO
SEE COUNTRIES DECIDE WHETHER ORM
SEE COUNTRIES DECIDE WHETHER ORV
SEE COUNTRIES DECIDE WHETHER ORE
SEE COUNTRIES DECIDE WHETHER ORT
SEE COUNTRIES DECIDE WHETHER ORR
EMBASSIES TO JERUSALEM OR THEY
WANT TO KEEP THEM IN OTHER
PLACES.
>> David: ALL RIGHT,
GENTLEMEN, LET'S BRING THIS
THAT HAS BEEN -- WE HAVE SEEN A
SEA CHANGE IN YEARS, DECADES
LONG POLICY, AT LEAST SINCE THE
'90s AND HOW WE DEAL WITH
NORTH KOREA.
FIRST TO YOU, AMBASSADOR BOLTON.
RUSSIA NOW SAYING, AND THIS CAME
OUT OF THE NEWS THIS MORNING,
THEY ARE WILLING TO BE THE
BROKER OF A DEAL BETWEEN U.S.
AND NORTH KOREA.
BUT FROM A HISTORICAL TRACK,
WHAT DO WE SEE AND WHERE ARE WE
NOW WITH NORTH KOREA?
COULD RUSSIA PLAY A ROLE?
>> NO, I THINK IT WOULD BE A
WASTE OF OXYGEN.
WE HAVE NEGOTIATED WITH
NORTH KOREA FOR 25 YEARS.
THEY HAVE LIED EVERY TIME, THEY
HAVE MADE THAT COMMITMENT.
THERE IS IN PLAY NO EVIDENCE
THAT IN YOUR 26 THE
NORTH KOREANS ARE GOING TO DO
THIS ANY DIFFERENTLY.
IN FACT, WE HAVE GOT TONIGHT A
VERY INTERESTING COMPARISON.
REUTERS HAS A STORY THAT SAYS
CHINA'S TO TEXAS SHOWED NO OIL
EXPORTED HER NORTH KOREA LAST MN
EXPORTED HER NORTH KOREA LAST MH
EXPORTED HER NORTH KOREA LAST M.
BUT WE HAVE PAPERS PUBLISHED IN
THE SOUTH KOREAN PRESS OVERNIGHT
SHOWING AT LEAST 30 EXAMPLES OF
SHIP TO SHIP TRANSFERS OF OIL
BETWEEN CHINESE AND NORTH KOREAN
VESSELS DURING THE LAST COUPLE
OF MONTHS.
SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE BEEN PLAGUED BY THE
NORTH KOREANS, PLAYED BY THE
CHINESE FOR A LONG TIME.
I THINK WE ARE STILL WAITING FOR
CHINA TO DO SOMETHING DRAMATIC.
BUT IF IT DOESN'T, WE ARE FACED
WITH SOME VERY, VERY UNPLEASANT
CHOICES.
UNLESS YOU ARE PREPARED TO SEE
>> David: ALL RIGHT, SO,
DR. PARKER, YOU HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THIS SOME DEGREE,
YOU HAVE TRAVELED A GREAT DEAL
TO BRIEF OTHERS AND TALK ABOUT
THIS ISSUE.
WALK US THROUGH THE SCENARIO OF
WHERE WE ARE NOW AND WHAT WE
SHOULD DO OR NOT DO.
>> THIS IS A COMPLEX ENVIRONMENT
IN THE BACKYARD OF CHINA,
SOUTH KOREA, JAPAN, AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THOSE THREE COUNTRIES,
AND WHAT THEY ARE DEALING WITH
RIGHT NOW, IF THEY DO NOTHING,
IF WE DO NOTHING, AS A GLOBE,
PROGRAM AND ADVANCE THEM TO THE
POINT THAT THEY ARE CLOSE TO YOU
RIGHT NOW, WHAT YOU ARE GOING TO
END UP WITH IS LIKELY A NUCLEAR
SOUTH KOREA, A NUCLEAR JAPAN,
AND THEREFORE, A CONCERNED CHINA
THAT INCREASES THEIR NUCLEAR
CAPABILITY AND THEIR DEFENSE
I GETS BETTER BECAUSE THEN, IRAN
SEES HER NORTH KOREA "GOT AWAY
WITH IT" AND WHAT YOU END UP
WITH IS A POTENTIAL OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS IN AND AROUND THE GOLF,
AS WELL.
IF THAT HAPPENS, YOU ARE GOING
TO END UP LOSING CONTROL OF THAT
MATERIAL AND THAT IS A VERY
COMPLICATED PROBLEM.
WE HAVEN'T EVEN TALKED ABOUT
FINANCES AND ISSUES OF THE
IMPACT ON THE ECONOMY AT.
WHERE ARE WE WITH THE MEN WERE
DEBASED AND?
>> SOUTH KOREA IS INTERESTING
BECAUSE BEFORE WE CAN TALK ABOUT
THE UNIFIED KOREA, YOU HAVE TO
TALK ABOUT A UNIFIED
SOUTH KOREA.
TO TALK ABOUT A UNIFIED
WANT TO UNIFY THAT PENINSULA AND
WHETHER OR NOT YOU WANT WMD
WITHIN SOUTH KOREA ITSELF.
IF YOU TALK TO GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS OVER THERE, MANY OF
THEM ALL SAY THAT YOU NEED A
DESTRUCTION CAPABILITY FROM
SOUTH KOREA TOWARD THE
THING.
>> David: ALL RIGHT, BACK TO
COLD WAR IN MODERN FORM?
EFFORT TO PREVENT THE
PROLIFERATION OF WEAPONS OF MASS
WITH THERMONUCLEAR WEAPONS, THEN
I THINK THAT EFFORT WILL HAVE
NORTH KOREA.
THEY WILL SELL THESE
CAPABILITIES TO ANYONE WITH HARD
CURRENCY, TO IRAN, IF THEY ARE
TERRORIST GROUPS, IF THEY CAN
COME UP WITH THE MONEY, TO OTHER
NUCLEAR WEAPON STATES.
THEN YOU'RE GOING TO SEE THIS
PROLIFERATION WORLDWIDE.
IT WILL BE A MUCH MORE DANGEROUS
WORLD.
TRUMP INHERITED THIS.
HE DIDN'T CREATE THE SITUATION.
BUT IT WILL BE ON HIS WATCH THAT
WE EITHER STOP OR DO NORTH KOREA
ARE WE FACE A REAL EXPANSION OF
NUCLEAR -- AND ACTUALLY
BIOLOGICAL AND CHEMICAL WEAPONS,
AS WELL, ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
>> David: DR. BILL PARKER, CEO C
>> David: DR. BILL PARKER, CEO O
AT THE EAST-WEST INSTITUTE.
AND AMBASSADOR BOLTON, YOU HAVE